what I'm speaking now I say to people oh
well you're nowhere near what you could
be that's that that's the positive
message it's like yeah you're a mass but
you don't have to stay that way
identify what you want to change you got
to figure out what the thing is that you
want to go off and be the mindset is the
operating system of our lives and I'm an
absolute believer in cutting out
negativity going on the offense rise and
shine it's an spresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's start
your day off right grab your coffee and
sip on today's message change yourself
over to you Jordan Peterson
[Music]
psychologists have been not all
psychologists obviously but the
psychological profession is its neck
deep in this in this pathology has been
beating the self-esteem drum for 50
years
oh no you're okay you should feel good
about yourself like you're fine the way
you are it's like you think well that's
a calming message for people it's like
no it's not it's not at all and I watch
my audiences is like it's full of people
in the audience who think I'm suffering
a lot more than I think is tenable a
whole bunch of it's my fault my life is
not in the order it should be I know I'm
doing 50 things wrong it's like what the
hell's wrong with me what's wrong with
the people around me this is really
serious and some you know well-meaning
person comes up and says oh you're okay
just the way you are it's like no one
wants that message it's like no I'm not
okay the way I am I'm not okay at all
the way I am I know that and so you know
when I'm when I'm speaking to to when
I'm speaking now I say to people oh
you're nowhere near what you could be
that's that that's the positive message
it's like yeah you're a mess but you
don't have to stay that way cause you're
a mess you know it obviously you're
suffering away like like so much you can
barely tolerate it it's like that's okay
you can do something about it so yeah
that's the thing that that turns the
lights on it's like you have do
something about it so I believe that
everybody has Michael Jordan level
talent said it
the intro it's in the beginning of
almost all my videos I think you could
be the greatest in the world at
something and most people come nowhere
close ever to discovering that because
they lock themselves in on a certain
path and they end up hating their life
for the rest of their life and that's on
you to fix it it's on you to change it I
think you have the ability to be a
genius at something you're just not
there yet and the key thing is yet along
your journey of self-discovery of
figuring out what that thing is
you're gonna stumble upon lots of
different things you should try a whole
bunch of different things if you have no
idea what you want to be then the answer
is to try try try try try say yes to
everything at least once to see doesn't
make you come alive do you want to come
back and do it again and you're gonna
suck a lot at everything as you try out
all these different things until you
find the thing that you want to go back
and do even Michael Jordan when he first
started basketball he wasn't Michael
Jordan yet right he had to practice he
had to learn he had to get better he had
to work at it and so once you find the
thing that you have the ability to do
great things with then you need to work
hard at doing it and so I agree with
Jordan Peterson in that if you are
unhappy with where you are in your life
and you feel like you're destined for
something greater then change yourself
you're responsible go out take the
action you may not be there yet but you
can if you work really hard on it okay
so then the question becomes how do I do
it that's great I know I want to do
something more than I'm at right now I
want to do something else how do I go
off and actually do it here are three
steps to help you one identify what you
want to change you got to figure out
what the thing is that you want to go
off and be do you want to be a
basketball player you want to be
professor do you want to be a youtuber
what is it that you want to do what is
it that you want to be what is it that
you want to change if you don't know
what it is that you want to do then your
immediate responsibility should be the
figure out what it is that you want to
do you're not gonna figure it out by
just watching this video or by sitting
on the couch reading a magazine what are
you spending your time on like if you
don't know what you want to do in life
how are you doing anything else instead
of figuring out what it is that you want
to do in life stop turning on Netflix
stop turning off your life and escaping
from it and build something build
something that you can be proud of you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something you have to go out and figure
out what that is for your sake for your
families for communities for the world
you need to figure out what that thing
is so step one is like
NFI what it is that you want to change
step two is change your environment your
product of your environment forever and
always the people that you surround
yourself with the resources that you
consume your physical environment you
are a product of that and so if you want
to be world-class basketball player like
Michael Jordan then you need to be
around people who want to be like
Michael Jordan to their own version of
it you need to be around people who are
playing ball you're out there practicing
with them you need to be consuming
Michael Jordan content on a daily basis
it's why I made this channel it's to
give you the mindset and the motivation
on a daily basis is there's always no
videos you don't need to watch the same
video 100 times because it's gonna lose
its efficacy over time there's always
new baby hoes every day three new pieces
for you to consume that hopefully
something resonates with you that if you
surround yourself with that if you love
Jordan Peterson if you are watching
Jordan Peterson on a daily basis you
will start to think like him your
mindset will shift your belief systems
will shift your perspective will shift
to be more like him if you hate him then
then don't don't watch him there's lots
of people in the world that you can
model and so most people wake up like an
accident
changing your morning routine to be
something that supports you if you want
it to be world-class at something and
you surrounded yourself with videos
books podcasts resources people who
thought that way and on a daily basis
and you consume that that's the first
thing needed every morning your life
will transform your life in one year
will not be recognizable compared to
where you are today because you change
your environment stop blaming your
environment stop blaming your parents
and your friends in the school and all
the things that were against you great
that happened embrace it you have the
responsibility to change it and you can
and so feed yourself with things that
build you up and make you feel amazing
do that with intention every single
morning instead of waking up like an
accident and step number three is get
some accountability whatever the thing
is that you want to work on and prove if
you have somebody in your life who can
hold you accountable for it really helps
you because you may not always catch the
moments where you mess up quick example
I wanted to complain less and so I told
the people in my life my wife my people
on my team if you ever catch me
complaining I want you to tell me hey
you're complaining and everybody said
you don't complain like we've never hear
you complain it's like I complain I'm
not the Dalai Lama I complain a lot I'm
not a perfect human being I might not be
complaining all the time
I might be great 90% of the time but
that 10% is what I want to fix
so if you ever catch me complaining I
want you to call me out on it my son in
particular Hayden loves love's calling
me out on it when I complain and he's a
daddy you're complaining you're
complaining you're complaining he really
enjoys it and what can i I asked him to
write I asked him to call me out on it
and so if you have people in your life
who you can say listen whenever I do
this behavior this is what I want to
change this is the person that I want to
be if you ever catch me doing this
behavior I want you to let me know and
then when they call you out on it even
though you might be frustrated angry in
the moment you say thank you because
they're helping you recognize that
pattern in yourself and helping you get
to where you want to be now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're going to enjoy but before that
question of the day I want to know what
is the one thing that you need to change
most about yourself what is the thing
that you wish you had people in your
life that you are now gonna change to
get some accountability around what's
the thing that you need to change
leaving the comments below
when you write it down it's much more
likely to happen so leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
I for example as you know don't love
positioning myself as a motivational
speaker I'm even the content you just
saw but no question the mindset is the
operating system of our lives and I'm an
absolute believer in cutting out
negativity going on the offense like
positive thinking like what's the
alternative
like practicality I'm a big believer in
that stuff but action is really the
biggest thing huh in happened and I do
believe that the right mindset leads to
the right actions so yes I do think
you've listened to me it's about getting
poison out of the system right right I
mean look then we people use in your
situation yeah right yeah because that's
what they decide to think about right
you did it right the end right it's I
narrate right and so you know one of the
things I do often is the people around
me they're thinking about negativity I'm
like what's the alternative there's so
much negative out of people right you're
positive they're running around with
their legs and complaining right right
so I'm with you I couldn't agree more
yeah how to do something is the wrong
sequence to start with like what's the
strategy for being fit and healthy it's
not that complex and yet 70% of the u.s.
is overweight like he doesn't have to do
it it's not a strategy problem what it
is is why are they doing it it's because
they have a story and everyone does is
entrepreneurs business people everyone
does this when we get fearful when we've
tried something that we're not
succeeding as fast as we want when we
are afraid of failing we come up with a
story about how it's not our fault or
how we're gonna do it in the future
because they don't have to feel bad
feeling bad makes us have to deal with
it most people are overwhelmed so they
just they come up with a story that I
tried everything
did you tried everything you'd be fit
you know I tried millions millions name
of three things they did any times that
don't work man but I think if you can
come up when you change the story when
you come up with a new set of beliefs
you'll find yourself finding the
strategy or using the strategies that
already worked in there there that right
now your mind says all won't work and
the best way to change people you got
strategies story is state and I only
share this with distance owners you've
got to be able to produce a different
state of your people there has to be
something compelling there has to be a
sense of mission it's all mental and
people don't get it everybody wants to
say okay we wrote in steps - okay Lewis
said do 8et said do nine you know this
person says this - 12 steps and
everybody's trying to get two steps
without the mentality it's like okay
maybe you don't need all nine or maybe
you don't need all eight maybe you need
four maybe you need - well I don't know
but I think sometimes they see what we
do and say if I can imply kiff I can
duplicate that just like exactly how he
does in the book exactly and that's like
you know you have a story you know you
you having a unique experience and so
you're 12 are shaped by by not just your
world but how your world has shaped your
thinking and I think that's the part
that missions like guys you know if it
was easy everybody could do it if it was
a cookie cutter everybody would just
follow it to the tee but there's a
mindset and when I looked at Sarina
you know when I look at the Michael
Jordan's already Tom Brady you know you
look at Michael Phelps like it is a
mentality you know on our new album the
resolution I talk about I got that dog
and I'm not really referring to just
this you know aggressiveness but it is a
mindset
I saw Belichick said something where you
never like how you feeling about the
super boys I'm gonna be honest with you
with five weeks behind he's like
everybody else are next year next year -
is practicing training they lost you
know they day and so they're trying to
get ready lifting weights they're
reading book they're you know everybody
that lost his study he's like yeah we
find what type of mine says race in five
weeks behind international super I
didn't vote so but again it's a
mentality and I think a lot of people
are missing that mentality if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it won't you believe it you
act like I am Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning though thunder
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty-four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between thirty seconds and five minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access